hey 42 here have you ever been cold and
I don't mean when your nipples get a bit
frosty I'm talking about freezing
frostbite inducing coals the coldest
settlement on earth is oil economy in
Russia where temperatures average minus
50 degrees C and can drops you minus 71
degrees and those temperatures
if you cries the tears would instantly
freeze your eyes short blinding you and
without proper clothing you would surely
be dead within the hour
but there's a living organism that has
been with us long before the dinosaurs a
creature that has survived all five mass
extinctions that would find these frigid
temperatures no problem at all the six
hundred million year old tardigrade
tardigrades are micro animals
approximately 0.5 millimeters in length
they have a digestive tract and eight
with the legs but that's where the
similarity is to other animals and
unlike the residence of a macaque he was
Paris if they went outside without at
least 20 coats on the tardigrade can
survive at temperatures as low as minus
272 degrees Celsius that is one degree
above absolute zero the lowest
temperature physically possible within
our universe at these temperatures even
atoms stopped moving even when it can't
get any colder the humble tardigrades
just keeps on going the tardigrade
sometimes called a water bird because of
its little claws is the most
indestructible animal on the planet they
are practically immortal as well as
surviving the lowest temperatures in the
universe tardigrade can survive heat up
to 150 degrees Celsius pressures six
times greater than those found in the
deepest ocean trenches on earth and
ionizing radiation 100 times higher than
the lethal dose for a human this little
guy could literally chill out inside the
reactor core which two novels and be
completely fine but most amazingly
evolved and unique to this creature the
tardigrade can go without any food or
water for over 30 years but how well
they die the tardigrade can dehydrate
itself like a ready meal from back to
the future to the point where it is less
than 3% water the human body is 60%
water in this ultra deep hibernation
known as cryptobiosis the tardigrade has
no need for any sustenance and can
sustain this state for thirty years
after which it simply rehydrates itself
and comes back to life to forage for
food and reproduce if it's in the mood
they don't technically died while
dehydrated it's more a status suspended
animation and the single tardigrade can
live to be over a century old NASA sent
thousands of tardigrade into space where
they were sent out into the total vacuum
of space for days on end where they were
subjected to massive solar radiation
they came back alive and well what's
more some of the tardigrades had given
birth to lots of little tardigrade
babies out in the vacuum of space the
most inhospitable place imaginable and
the space babies were also completely
normal and healthy on their return to
earth to date they are the only animals
we know of that has gone defenseless
into the total vacuum of space and lived
to tell the tale some scientists even
speculate that tardigrades are actually
alien and actually came to our planet
from another planet such as Mars over a
billion years ago because their DNA is
so strange and unlike anything we've
ever seen before but these aren't some
grad beasts exclusively found under a
single rock in Antarctica tardigrades
are literally everywhere odds are you
are only a few metres from a tardigrade
right now that's because they live in
mosses and
and where do you find muff well it only
covers the entire planet
they feed on plant cells so the Muhsin
littering provides a perfect hosing and
dump home although they do mostly eat
plants tardigrades have been known to
cannibalize each other and they're also
not exclusive to moths either they have
also been found at the top of the
tallest mountains in the Himalayas in
size hot springs in Japan at the very
bottom of the ocean and deep within the
Antarctic wilderness so basically
everywhere you see
tardigrades just don't give a crap about
anything one of the most amazing
tardigrade abilities is how they deal
with the extreme cold and extremely low
temperatures ice crystals can form
inside the cells of a life-form ripping
apart the cell's vital components such
as its DNA which is always fatal to that
organism some animals have evolved to
cope with the extreme cold
for example fish in cold regions make
antifreeze that lowers the freezing
point of their cells stopping ice and
forming and preventing fatal frost
damage the scientists however have found
no evidence of antifreeze
inside tardigrades their way to balance
for that instead tardigrades simply
tolerates the ice forming inside their
cells they just don't care amazingly
they are able to quickly repair any
damage caused by the ice crystal by
rapidly creating antioxidants they also
produce nucleating agents that encourage
ice to form around the cell instead of
inside of it but what is truly baffling
about this tiny immortal bear is how it
deals with extreme heat at temperatures
as high as 150 degrees Celsius a cell's
membrane should unravel and it would be
torn apart this would happen to all
cells simultaneously quickly killing the
cells host tardigrades have been heated
to a hundred and fifty degrees C for 15
minutes and what happens absolutely
nothing it just carried out scuttling
around as though
had been quietly sunbathing yes
scientists still have no idea how they
do this it shouldn't be possible for
cell to survive at these temperatures
yes they do naturally scientists are now
studying a microscopic tardigrade to try
and unlock the secrets of its
immortality
maybe we can steal a secret or two for
awesome thanks for watching
[Music]